welcome to the ass Evan show episode
number five where I answer your business
questions so let's get to it first
question from diarrhea diarrhea I hope I
pronounced that properly Evan can you
make a video about how to go about it
when you just want to help people at a
professional level is going into HR okay
i am in a community college right now
and I don't like the mandatory subjects
and therefore my GP is going down what
should i do I don't I get asked a lot
about advice for college students where
they should go what they should do I
guess same thing with entrepreneurs
where they should go we should do with
all big topics okay any important big
decision that you have to make for
yourself you always have to listen to
your heart you have to make all
important decisions with your heart and
then the smaller decisions with your
head ok so your GP is going down you're
in a corset you don't like you're taking
all of these mandatory subject so you
don't like so what are you going to do
about you got to move towards something
that you do like right it's great that
you have this this anger towards
something that you don't like now you
know what you don't want to do that's
awesome that that's great that's
education that's learning now it's
taking that I'm moving this help the nut
you do love to do what gets you excited
if you're going around your campus ok
you open up the book of all the
different courses which one do you read
in there that you love that gets you
excited so I really want to try that one
that's where you should go and not worry
about following into what you know
specific bucket and where that's going
to line you up in the future you don't
know how the dots are going to connect
looking forward you only know how they
can connect looking backwards so you
have to follow your passion right follow
your curiosity get lost in something so
when you look at your next courses pick
the ones that excite you that invigorate
you that make you want to learn that
make you want to show up the class
you're going to probably get great
grades in that and that's going to open
up huge opportunities for you going
forward so that's HR great go in the HR
kill it in HR if it's not a charred
that's just something that you think is
a good thing to do then don't do it go
do something else you have to follow
what excites you follow your flow do
things that make you come alive ok next
question comes from M jit Berlin
have been very good video thank you is
another YouTube viewer one question how
do you track people's actual work time
thanks this is going to come down to
what your philosophy as an entrepreneur
is and what your management style is ok
I am NOT a micromanager I hate having to
micromanage people I hate having to
track their time and say well you work X
number of hours it drives me nuts I hate
being micromanage myself and so I try
not to impose out on other people and if
my business relied on me having to be a
micromanager to be successful I would
fail it wouldn't work out and so I
instead of managing people's time I
instead hire people who I trust to be
good at managing their own time and I
give them projects and I give them
assignments and and we have deadlines
some things have to get done by a
certain date and and I trusted they're
doing a good job for me and if I soon as
I lose that trust as soon as I start
thinking I think I think this person is
ripping me off i think this person's not
doing their job then then it's not going
to work out right if you don't have
trust between yourself and your
employees it's over in my view other
people they thrive on that they have to
track every single thing they you know
have punch cards or whatever it is and
you know it's just not for me a lot of
people who are higher on odesk are the
number people my full-time team from
odesk odesk actually allows you to track
people's hours in time and it's built
into their system so on the back end it
tracks when somebody logs in they
started work for you right they say okay
I'm going to work for for MZ berlin here
and they have to log in to click record
it starts recording their screen it
starts recording their their keystrokes
right and they know this has happened
this is big brother but they know that
it's happening so they're not they're
not in the dark about this and any time
you want you can go in and look at what
they're doing in the computer you could
look at how active they are with their
with their keyboard right and their
mouths to see if they're just on the
same screen or they actually doing work
and moving it around so at any time with
Otis you can do that but again for me if
I have to go into everybody's profile
and
make sure that they're doing what
they're supposed to be doing I feel like
I've done a bad job in hiring I feel
like that person is not really committed
if I have to use that as a way to make
sure they're doing the right thing so
you can do it if you want odesk you to
the tools but from my view I think you
gotta hire better okay next up Petrus
for my newsletter list rights in to say
hi how are you I am fine Petrus thank
you for asking give me ideas on how to
create YouTube tutorials in mathematics
statistics and economics this is awesome
so I recently actually launched a video
on Tim Schmoyer channels got a channel
that supports people who are trying to
create YouTube videos I wrote about 10
ideas 10 creative ways no but ideas for
your YouTube channel and I I need to
have a lot of content i'm making two
videos every single day on my channel
what i would start with though for you
so you're interested in mathematics
statistics economics find one thing that
is a big problem in that market what's a
big problem in mathematics or in
statistics or an economics what's
something that you really struggled with
as a student what's something that you
see a lot of students struggling with
and a quick way that you can overcome it
or how do you solve that big problem
take a stance on something have an
opinion on something so just give me a
boring mathematics lesson make it
personal right tell me about how you
struggle to solve legit tell me a story
about how one of the people who you've
tutored had to go through this and how
you helped solve it make it make it mean
something because most of these videos
that cover this kind of stuff is going
really boring really dry not much
personality this is your chance to stand
out okay and I I use their feedback and
suggestions right every time your
meeting with the mathematics student and
you're helping them solve a big problem
that could be a new video for you right
if you have a weekly video that's coming
out helping solve the problems of your
students ever coming to you then
eventually you'll get feedback on your
channel right at the end of every video
you can ask hey you guys have any
questions leave a comment below I'd be
happy to make a video response to you
that's what I do right most of my
channel that's how it started was
certain questions from you guys people
would ask me business questions how to
start their business anything rated to
entrepreneurship and I would write these
long detailed emails back I thought this
is crazy like I'm spending way too much
time on this and I'm only helping that
one person where I thought now hey if I
could do YouTube videos then I can help
that person in a much more visual way a
lot faster but also help reach a wider
audience of other people who also have
that same problem and so this whole show
right the ask Evan show is all about
your questions coming in so you could
eventually do a ask Petra's show all
about mathematics and statistics and
economics but start by making videos
that you feel passionate about that are
big problems that are coming to you from
students at your coaching and then at
the end of every video ask for feedback
from your audience and and as you get
comments then you make videos to help
your community up that's how you start
I'm excited and save me the channel I'm
curious to see this mathematics
statistics of economics channel so when
you see this video pop a comment and
drop the link to your channel next up
Jacob is a loyal YouTube audience
subscriber kommentarer always post great
questions he wrote in to say hey I'm
going to have a question do you watch
the Dragons Den do you think these types
of shows are good to watch when pitching
for an investment today or are they
unrealistic any favorite pictures in
particular and what can we learn from it
thanks I love dragons den one of my
favorite shows I've watched pretty much
every single episode when they were
coming to Canada they actually CBC asked
me to be involved in the launch to help
promote it to Canadians as a as a new TV
show I think there's not enough quality
programming for entrepreneurs you think
about how many people want to be
entrepreneurs but how many people want
to start their own business at every
level in school and university in the
workforce how do people want to start
their own business there's tons and then
how much content actually reflects that
in the mainstream media right if you
want to start your own businesses no
there's no entrepreneur channel there's
no entrepreneur network on TV that you
can go and watch and so I think shows
like dragons den and that evolved the
Sharks tank in the US and Marcus lemonis
is a show called The Prophet huge train
of all those shows highly recommended
one to get some ideas so
you're looking at an investment today
yeah you'll get some ideas of what
investors look at I mean these are angel
investors and they have their own set of
criteria right there's five angels on
the on the Dragons Den and they'll be
slightly different than going to a
venture capitalists are going to other
angel investors but it's still it's a
good start so gives you a little bit of
an education it gives you a sense of the
types of questions people will ask right
think about every question that's been
asked to someone who's pitched a lot of
the questions are repeat questions you
should be able to answer all those
questions for your company right imagine
you go through the last year of dragons
den and you got kevin O'Leary grilling
those entrepreneurs imagine he asked you
every one of those questions would you
be able to answer them if you can you
probably do a great job going into the
investment pitch you can't then you
probably have some homework to do in
terms of my favorite episode I actually
I do have one favorite pitch I posted on
my website I posted on my on my youtube
channel it's with Arlene Dickinson
invested in the company and then brought
his product across the country selling
it and brought him up for reveal and was
crying and had an impact on me and
reminded me that the Entrepreneurship
again is not just about making money but
also having an impact and and creating
positive change so check out that
episode it's had a lot of views and all
the comments and you know give it a like
and a thumbs up and in a comment but to
also check out dragons and sharks tank
and the profit next up a Facebook fan
Nicholas thank you for leaving a comment
wrote in the same I'm trying to
recognize my mistakes you know what what
I did wrong and try to move on what I
recently due to find the positive side
because there is something positive
every situation what do you do Evan how
do you face failure have a great weekend
failure is a part of success and failure
is a part of being an entrepreneur and
this is something a lot of people don't
understand especially when they're
getting started you will fail that's
okay you will know failure on your path
of success entrepreneurs fail their way
to success the key is to not let a
failure get you down and I know it can
be hard if you have a big failure and
you struggled and and you kind of put
everything you have into this
one idea and if it didn't work out then
you feel like like life is over right
that maybe this isn't meant for you and
and you're not quite sure what to do
next and it can cause a lot of despair
and anger and uncertainty what I try to
do is I try to fail small so I'll try a
whole bunch of different things things
that I'm interested in things I'm
curious about things I want to explore
and I see one do I enjoy it am I getting
something from it i am I feeling like
I'm contributing to the world by doing
this right you can have an idea but
until you start trying it you don't know
what's going to happen right so am I am
I getting energy from this am I liking
it and two is it working right am I
seeing results am I am I getting
traction from this and a great example
is making these videos when I first
started the channel I didn't know if I
would be committed to making a channel
now you know I had five different
marketing ideas making YouTube videos as
one of them and I started trying all of
them to see what stuck and eventually
the YouTube one stuck right I'm still
here still doing more videos increasing
the views and the subscribers and more
and more videos or keep coming up and I
didn't spend all the money and all the
time at the start you know I didn't I
didn't invest in the best gear and
camera i just started what i had but I
could start with this I can start with
my laptop right here I'll get Sturgis
with this right that's all you need to
start so if I fail that it didn't work
out then it'd be a small failure right
at invest in time but but no real
dollars and if it worked out then I
continued invest more and more into it
so one don't be so afraid of failure
right failure will happen everybody has
has it everybody goes through it it's
not something that you fail you're the
only one in the world you feel lonely
and n you suck right everybody goes
through it and to just try to make sure
that the failures are small failures try
something try something try something
try something small starts small starts
and see if you like it's you forgetting
results and it's okay it's okay to shut
them down I think if you're failing a
lot like I fail I feel tons I feel all
the time this ask Evans show that could
have been a failure right the first
episode 1 episode 5 now the first
episode I put out I said someone that I
got
know if I'm gonna I don't know this a
good format what do you guys think are
you enjoying this and I'd sit down and
you know what I had I have a good time I
like doing the ask Evan show I'm having
a good time doing this you guys seem to
like you were leaving comments and so I
keep doing it but I could have done the
one episode I've done other videos that
I've tried and it didn't work you know
and and I you know I didn't really have
a good result good experience with it
and so I stopped it so it's okay like I
fail more than I succeed I fail all the
time and that's okay you should be okay
with failure try not to fail big you
know minimize the downside of your
failure and move on to something else
the more you fail the more comfortable
yet with it and the closer you get to
your next success let's sit another US
government in the books let me know what
you guys think leave a comment ask the
question below you liked this video you
want to see more like it subscribe to
the channel keep believing thank you so
much I'll see you soon Christina we
could pop the video right here as I'm
talking can we put it like our position
put it in oh this way let me see trying
to put it in my hands can we put it
right here here's the video leave
playlist here comes the Sun big so much
watch Xbox up let's get the show on the
road don't forget to sign up for my free
newsletter its energy in your inbox
every single week hi i'm jason j reyez
fonseka of Ra's online com and i want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period